life is not something you get to play
again it is one shot game and everything
I think about is mitigating and
eliminating regret and I think this
incredible thought you're going through
the answer is always going to be yes
because even if it doesn't work you even
going through the Journey is the win
because you cannot allow yourself in 30
40 years asking yourself sitting there
saying why didn't I do that and so it's
not risk it's actually the reverse the
risk is not doing and sitting with that
pit in your stomach for the rest of your
life so my answer is please go make the
jump we're cheering for you let us know
if we can
help